The Joe Rogan Experience that was the
Terence McKinney fight right yeah that
was a wild fight it was a good fight oh
that was a crazy one that was that
Terence McKinney is wild did you see the
uh the sugar Shawn fight yes I did yeah
the look on his face at the end he's I
was like he normally runs his mouth
pretty good he's a good old Arizona boy
but like he had that look on his face
like I did I win that did I win like
he's well he was very honest he said I'm
gonna have to watch this yeah afterwards
to see if if I actually won it yeah
um a lot of people were shocked yeah uh
there's a video of khabib watching the
decision
and it khabib's like how how yeah how
how did he win how yeah I yeah I was I
was right there 50. I wasn't I wasn't
sure because I I thought the other guy
won but
I think the bigger takeaway is that
he was in it oh he was certainly in it
against Peter yawn he was a former
Champion one of the best yeah in the
division by far the number one Contender
it was a very close fight and he
definitely hurt pylder in multiple
occasions caught him with that big knee
rocked him the question is uh how much
is the takedown worth how much is
control Worth right and my my I assumed
that when I saw all the takedowns like
then then Yan won because there's a lot
of takedowns yeah but takedowns without
damage it's like what is that Val I mean
and I'm not no I'm not denying that I
thought pilda yon won because I did
think he won at the end of it but
takedowns without damage versus stand up
with damage because
sugar landed more strikes standing and
had big moments John had some big
moments too one big left hand that
rocked him the question is like
how much is the how valuable are those
takedowns and how valuable is that top
game and that control and that's that's
way out of my you know the problem
there's several problems but one of the
problems is that I feel and I've said
this ad nauseam that I feel that we're
very limited by this 10-9 this 10 10
point musk scoring system
um because someone could win around 10-9
and it can be a very close round and
someone can win win around clearly and
it could be 10-9 right and that doesn't
make any sense to me and I feel like I
mean the system is designed for boxing
and and it's a good system for boxing I
don't think it's a good system for MMA I
think MMA needs a much more
comprehensive system
like if a guy can hold you down with no
damage at all for three minutes
versus a guy who holds you down and
damages you for 30 seconds or what's
worth more you know what hits you with
three or four good hard shots is that
worth more or is like the predominance
of a like if you you spend the majority
of a round on top of a guy even if
you're not damaging him how much is that
worth
what are how much is a leg kick worth
how's how much is a submission worth
like a submission attempt
I think we need a much more
comprehensive system that it doesn't
it's not 10 point must I don't think
that's the right system for for MMA I
think it should be a completely
different system we just sort of adopted
the boxing system so like the first
round of algerman Sterling and TJ
Dillashaw I mean that is a [ __ ]
dominant round like what is that is it a
10-7 is it a 10-6 I mean that's on all
algae main round he beat the [ __ ] out of
TJ Dillashaw took him down dominated him
took his back beat the [ __ ] out of him
like what's that how do you score that
round and you know how could you know
how how could that be better scored with
a better system right I think there's uh
there's definitely there's definitely I
can feel like that that UFC was probably
my top five ufcs ever it was amazing we
watched it
um Jamie uh hooked it up from my iPad to
a television through an HDMI connection
in the O2 Arena we're in London we just
did the show we had no idea what
happened luckily we got off stage
ordered food and Jamie set up the iPad
to a big screen TV that was in the room
we're all in there it was like 20 of us
in there watching it was funny
incredible it was incredible he'll sue
you no he wanted me to he gave me the
[ __ ] gave me the link to it I have a
Fight Pass membership but that's how we
watched it but it was such a good fight
and then watching Islam and and Charles
Oliveira that was what a fight that was
must have the most incredible squeeze
his his squeeze must be out of this
world because you see how quick Charles
tapped once he clamped that on him I
mean poof
yeah he had all the points covered and
he just like yeah done that dude is on
another level
I mean I am he is the truth I am so I
was always impressed with him but I mean
I was saying leading up to him getting a
shot at the world title he's the
boogeyman of that division he was the
guy that everybody was saying like is
the the most dominant of all the
contenders and then when he tapped over
that was a big one when he tapped Dan
hooker that was a big one too it's like
the way he's tapping these guys who are
these world-class Fighters he's just
[ __ ] running through them but the
fact that he got on Oliveira and mounted
him and then submitted him with an arm
triangle had an arm choke like that
yeah that's a statement he submitted the
guy with the most submissions in the
history of the sport
and the way he did it was just he was so
[ __ ] methodical and dominant and
Oliveira tested him I mean he got out of
bad positions in the first round he got
back up to his feet hit him with some
good shots but makachev he's the [ __ ]
truth
you know there's and interesting that
he's going to fight vulcanovsky next
that's kind of a crazy thing for
volkonowski to go right up to 55 from 45
yeah